let's try another one here
wow
oh unavailable we don't available
what's going on really mama's safest boy
here you're right next to say goodbye
to the final show
that you see here this fun show that we
produce
every week two weeks who knows what it
is you just call it a complaint anyways
anyways the final cut got some kick-ass
bands especially in the twos here
tonight
i don't know what's going on it's a
crazy matter lots of them
we put your feet in your pocket so high
the guy on the right is
so high right
oh no
first call you hope you got some
chickens
hello hello chicken here all right
you guys the show is really uh well i
don't know what is this
violated i like to call it violated yes
hey you want to talk to my um my mom
your mom what's her name
hello hello mother hello well hey
what you gonna say baby you got some
chickens for me
mom no oh sorry i should have been a
little shy that's all right i like
chocolate chips too cookies
oh really cookies oh cookies
special cookies uh good cookies they
like chocolate chip
they're not cow pie cookies all day
because i like some cows too
they're all great i like cookies what
are you doing with your cookies tossing
them throwing them what
i'm trying to figure out the accent this
guy's trying to do
cookies
you're cooking my brain thank you for my
time
no i do not know what i am i'm a doc hey
it's a car
that's great hey that's the street short
thing
that [ __ ] uh van diesel was promoting
yes well hey
yes you are on the lines speak brother
speak to us goddamn puppet show [ __ ]
speak to the shark or the sharks pissed
yeah queer dude
i just thank you for my time
yo man what's up
hey it's weird balls shut up
just because i have look i'm not gonna
[ __ ] on people that have a puppet you're
not gonna get me to do it
puppetry is an art form that's making a
comeback and i think people that bought
a puppet recently are pretty cool
testicles mounted on my chin
doesn't mean crap buddy i hope that
[ __ ] that complained in the ithaca
journal about you was watching right now
you know what let me tell you something
about her i'm not a penis
puppet okay what camera am i on here
okay i'm not
something we already knew morons that
sucks
so duck guy oh yeah what uh
what are you up to tonight well
after this i'm gonna go home and put a
gun down my [ __ ] throat
wow you know what i'm gonna do i don't
know what i'm gonna shave my chin
that was funny
that's a joke
that's just a joke is that a penis
puppet
hello
[Music]
you're like the most attractive guy i've
seen in months i know i i am
uh can i have your number and maybe we
could go out on a date baby
well i think i'm going to come down to
the studio later really when you come
down if you come down we make out me
live on tv bring friends for the redneck
guy i would make out with you
no matter what at any time chickens for
me
those those [ __ ] those public access
broads man
those [ __ ] public access broads
all right you said something called the
gorgeous george show i'll put it on
it's not public access i think it's just
a youtube show but we'll check it out
the old school fecal related music
right has to do with well tonight
tonight we're going to talk about the
specialities
and the food that you see in these fancy
restaurants
it's directable to the palette it's an
explosion in one's pants
now when you see these specials all
right so here's what happened with these
guys
i'll already tell you
i'm going to tell you what happened with
these guys these are guys that they go
out and hang out with their friends and
they're like the funniest guys in their
little group of friends and they're like
bro we could totally make it if we put a
show together we will be [ __ ]
hilarious together
that's what happened here right they're
like dude all we need
we we're riff dude like i can't do stand
up like we could riff like we're gonna
riffing with each other
and they figured oh we'll do a show
we'll just riff with each other
that's what i'm picking up here these
are dudes that go out and they drink
with the bros
and they [ __ ] just riff and they go
we're gonna riff dude it's gonna be
hilarious how we riff
oops these cocktail soups
we wonder where they come from
i like the soup there's very powerful
and very tasteful
called pea soup ah have you ever had pea
soup before
i have had this pea soup it's very
delicious
it goes really good down the esophagus
and makes
everything taste so good now
the pea soup that i like is the one with
toenail clippings toenail clippings from
just various adventurous amount of
people
and i also like the yellow i don't like
the green pea
i like the yellow pea yes because it's
more
tasteful and it has a little tang
fart and you might be you might have
come here because you were banned from i
don't care
this isn't where you complain about what
night wave did
okay
stop you know
very ask people here i really like the
band people list their [ __ ] sperms
spurgs are spamming
so you want to you want to be part of
the show that's fine
but don't come in here and whine
please the color it has that tang when
you stick it down your
throat and you gotta watch my show
but when you're not you should be trying
this pea soup the yellow colored piece
yeah yeah and you feel it it's groovy
man
yeah i'm sorry what character are you
doing because you're dressed like guy
fieri but wearing kanye west glasses but
you're talking like a [ __ ]
60s hippie when we have this
wonderful taste you know you have to be
able to smell
and be able to taste and smell and have
all the senses have all the senses you
can have
and i like the smell of fish
oh yes not just any kind of fish
but the lager fish maybe i'm going to
skip ahead
semen see semen and to go ahead and see
blood splotches from a period of okay
back up hold on what are we talking
about here resurfaced again
it's a second time around cleansing the
column colonical
cleavage yeah you're just re-cleansing
and your breath will be wonderful yes
yeah
what did they eat wow and you smell it
yeah and you sniff it yeah you even hear
it
oh yeah you see it and when you see it
you want to
taste it yes i always taste it in your
mouth and see an explosion i'm telling
you
nothing gets me more excited to see
semen
see semen and to go ahead and see
blood splotches from a period of a
beautiful woman
oh she can be it don't matter what she
looks like
but again it's beautiful yeah beautiful
is good
ideally but any woman's period stains
and splashes oh you just don't know
something you mix with all that you just
don't you know hey ladies is this
working for you
yeah yeah man
all that yeah now when we get into steak
ah what kind of steak do you like do you
kind of
something like it's shoe leather some
like it red
i used to like its shoe leather yeah but
i like it red because it means that
there's a red in the bread in the poop
red and the poop yes
see i like to take the steak i was
thinking about this before the show
and i prepared it in the toilet
like in the service station yeah i put
the grill
on top of the dirty toilets
so they probably work at a restaurant
together and they goof around in the
kitchen and thought this would be funny
i don't wipe it because you get rid of
the juices
and then you just light that up and you
cook it in those
juices juices
folks everybody can
share their juices in the steak that
they're going about are ready to cook
you take the knife you take the fork you
get the pot
you scoop it out like a fisher's net in
the toilet and then you preheat it on
the stove
and then when you've preheated the stove
put a little noodles on top of it to
cover it up a little bit
and then you can have yourself a [ __ ]
static
pasta
this is really gross i know some of you
are eating breakfast so i will apologize
for that um
oh man he has all different kinds of
wacky character you didn't tell me in a
bunch of different wacky characters
we've been out now
no we're not it's circling you're on
though
you're live all right folks we have been
out we we we've been out three different
times now the cameras cut off of
us on three different times i don't know
if there's the wi-fi signal here
going on
okay so far so good so far so but we
need to support this president
and we need to get off this trip upon
him
being a pedo and everybody being a pedo
in this q a
upon cuba oh let's check let's check
this guy out
saying that everybody is uh
you know this world's gonna go to hell
this world has already been to hell it's
it's you know earth is hell but we need
to support this president
bro that's so deep dude like earth is
hell man
it's [ __ ] earth as hell dude and we
need to get off
this trip upon him being a pedo
and everybody being a pedo in this q a
on trip
because i tell you what it is these
people are pretty damn scary
these people believe in queuing on and
you literally just did a skit where
you're eating period blood and come on a
steak
i mean we just saw you do it i mean do
it if you want i
fine with me but let's stop you're gonna
come but now i'm getting your [ __ ]
high orders
everybody's a pedo and save the children
is a front
they're scary terrorists they're scary
terrorist people out there
you hear that queuing on these [ __ ]
boomer retards
are terrorists
you hear that this president is going to
be a good president
let's give him a chance that's all i
gotta say do you give trump a chance
do you give trump a chance you [ __ ]
[ __ ] about that
we need to get off this trip upon this
person being a pedo
and that person being a pedo this man is
going to be
a great president that's joseph biden
joseph biden is our president
and let's support him joseph joseph
that's pretty much what it is a nutshell
this thing keeps cutting off of me
uh i don't know if there's uh you know
what's going on man ron bennington
really lost it huh
you used to love the guy uh we're gonna
i don't know if it's a computer or if
it's a wi-fi
uh it's getting to piss me offload but
i've already said what i needed to say
and we're trying to do a show
i wanted to do more but i can look at
myself where are you commenting on who i
am
and how gorgeous i am and all you ladies
have to do is gravitate to the computer
put your hand on the screen
and feel it all you have to do is put
your hand on the screen
and feel the presence that's right
uh so are
are we done i don't know we're i know uh
roger i feel bad because we've been cut
off
twice now you haven't i mean we wanted
to do some things but
we got some things going on right now
roger you got a thing you want to say to
the people out there
you got anything you want to say about
being american and being proud of it
well i'm not lee greenwood i'm talking
that awful song
right to be american at least
i know i'm free
america but i think times are
as of noon earlier today things are
going to change
and they're changing back to what was
normal truth will be true
what was normal oh [ __ ] you you know
it's just gonna make fun of your wacky
skits but what was
normal what was normal [ __ ] what
drone striking [ __ ] weddings huh is
that what was [ __ ] normal
chucking sucking china's [ __ ] [ __ ] is
that what was [ __ ] normal let's not
[ __ ] pretend oh
[ __ ] you i hate doing politics on dave
but [ __ ] this [ __ ] this guy
you [ __ ] serious dude right now are
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] with me
well we've always done it that way okay
so let's just [ __ ] keep doing it
let's just [ __ ] keep to what was
normal he did this on
january 21st a little bit after the
inauguration
what is normal huh being in the [ __ ]
middle east for 18 years
is that what's normal killing little
brown babies with [ __ ] bombs
that's what's [ __ ] normal to you
pretending the entire
[ __ ] middle of the country is a bunch
of redneck kick rubes
is that what's normal i want this guy on
my show now
i want him on my show now
we'll see liberty will be liberty let
liberty ring
and let liberty ring have some normalcy
normalcy like making videos about eating
[ __ ] covered period steak
is that what normal is to you vibes
coming out
good vibrations you give me a good
vibration
[ __ ] boomers he's probably not a
boomer he's probably gen xer but still
[ __ ] him
uh friends out there who are scared
of what will happen now just calm down
that's what i think we need yeah man
just like calm down
dude smoke a doob and calm
down matt shut up
it's time to take a chill pill
it's time to grab your crotch and ladies
out there this is ain't no for
the weak hearted it's time kevin finger
don't let cat don't because you know
grandma had a real time you know she was
cat
grandma has it was scarred for the rest
of her life watching yeah
grandma will never recover but we will
recover
this is going to be a good it's going to
be a good year
because it'll be four years and we're
it's going to be a good year so let's
let's talk about this was in january so
we're in february so it's been
almost a month and five days since this
see what we've done it's been a good
year
nobody got their stimulus check they
wasted their time impeaching somebody
that wasn't that they
they never impeached for a second time
uh
they we lost we did see the jobs today
how many
we lost more jobs than we were expected
to lose
everybody has to wear a [ __ ] mask you
have to wear an injection to get into an
airplane um let's see what else what
else oh yeah
we're at [ __ ] we're bombing the
middle east again
so that's pretty [ __ ] dope yeah i
don't know you're right you're right
they want to give amnesty to
11 million illegals which is probably
more like 20 million
if we're being being real uh but yeah no
everything's going great everything's
[ __ ] back to normal
the reason trump won was because people
were sick of your
normal normal [ __ ] sucked
your normal [ __ ] blue people were
dying of [ __ ] pain medication
on the [ __ ] streets in the midwest so
stop [ __ ] pretending all right
guess what before by before biting and
after bite and the same amount of people
are still being shot
[ __ ] dead in chicago so [ __ ] stop
with this normal
you guys you know what you guys what
these [ __ ] people like this
want they want they [ __ ] they want their
[ __ ] little [ __ ]
typical they want their little [ __ ]
typical
tv president they want a guy in a suit
to sit up there
and do this and tell them what they i'm
sorry do this
and tell them what they want to hear
that's what they want they want a
president that they can use in movies
and go oh he's
he's standing there with his hands
behind his back staring out the window
making tough decisions
you don't want a president you just want
life to go back to whatever [ __ ]
sitcom you think the [ __ ] american
dream is about i [ __ ]
hate people with this [ __ ] mentality
i really really [ __ ] do
this mentality is [ __ ] [ __ ]
and this is coming from a guy who said
what you want about me
i have criticized trump many a [ __ ]
times
many of [ __ ] times i think it would
have stayed off twitter it might have
helped them win
but [ __ ] this guy uh steve says serious
is why i hesitate doing these things
steve no you could do it you're a smart
guy these guys are [ __ ] retards
there's a difference
you're still waiting for you to do your
show stupid so do your show already
we are going to be able to see things
we've never seen before
we're going to be able to see through
our skeletons
you're going to be able to see your
skeleton in the mirror when you look at
yourself in the mirror
you're going to be able to see your
significant other skeleton
and it's going to smile right at you
thank you casey i think it's pretty good
nice haircut i do appreciate it the gray
sticking out like that but i do
appreciate it sports clips
give it a give it a ah makes sense he
goes to sports clips
giving a pump for sports clips yes sir
thank you there
casey and we're going to work on that
book here uh
roger's getting tired and so roger's got
to be off
off the races i have tried this camera
keeps cutting off
well i mean i think the camera [ __ ]
sees what we see who the [ __ ] wants to
watch you i'm just checking i want to
see
so it's called the gorgeous george show
on dvd apparently wait no
this is a stand-up he'd a stand-up
did he record it off of a tv oh no he's
[Music]
singing
[Music]
no i'm not gonna i don't want to sit
here and watch your boomer you [ __ ]
could you have the videos already online
i'm looking at a computer why don't you
just post it from there you [ __ ]
all right i want to address a few things
real fast so make this as
short as i can because it kills brain
cells even talk about these imbeciles
but here we go
uh they're at it again uh they keep
spinning the bottle keep doing this that
and the other
trying to get a reaction from me i only
come out when it's necessary to come out
i don't come out and make comments but
i'm going to say winning
once again you failed again um i got
tired of some [ __ ] this morning
so i said you know what meet me
somewhere
and once again they do their usual [ __ ]
they'll take pictures of my vehicle snap
pictures of me from afar
and telling me to come into an
establishment when they're not even
there
i didn't fall forward for one [ __ ]
bit i didn't walk into that
establishment i said you know what to
say to myself
this [ __ ] is impersonating me on
facebook and youtube he's impersonating
me using an email
so i told him i said look what's going
on who's he i need a little more
background
i guess people have been [ __ ] with
him
is that is that what i'm picking up here
people [ __ ] so when i'm
piecing together and i'm doing stuff as
we're playing the videos and people are
sending me things
um i guess he started
oh i got it
he started as a
public access show but now he's on
youtube okay let's see
okay what is causing all this my camera
needs to be raised up a little bit
anyway
fix it up baby all right so now we're
talking to you all we're talking to you
ladies out there
where have you been you haven't
had the opportunity to see
gorgeous george in the raw baby
every girl's fantasy is to see is he
doing
is he doing a ric flair impression
gorgeous george baby in the raw
we play a rotational schedule with this
station so
all you people deprived might not see
the full effect the wrecks and effect
because all i want to do is with my zoom
zoom in your boom boom and shake that
rom
no but see because we get on here and we
try to do a public service announcement
to all you fans out there that worship
us and worship
us and just want to bow down to me you
know good
god i mean i think i'm the next coming
of christ but you know is he trying to
do a wrestling gimmick maybe
next coming up prize next coming of uh
of the mack daddy
and then we've got vanilla ice and and
is his co-host paul simon
what's up wills todd bridges yeah now i
thought ty bridges
deodate or died on the on the right
and take danny barnabucho brucho on the
partridge family over
um bobby blair i thought the brady bunch
bobby yeah he's older there's a family
their name is brady i'll let you sing a
song
do it to a man one more time you know
once is never enough like a stud like me
oh yeah let me do it to you one more
time for the piano
once there's never enough like a stud
like me
all right we got uh we got rob
on hi talk to us hi
hi how you doing i'm doing how you doing
hey uh really quick question for you
what's up i thought you were a sponsor
the other day i was like i saw you
eating this there i was gonna say hi to
you and see what was up but you're stuck
in your fat
face daniel
hey george hi he's daniel for great
[Laughter]
oh god your mom jokes who the [ __ ] still
does those
and i was doing a uh bristle rub on her
area down there and she said and
obviously she has uh vernal disease
thank you very much
oh boy this is rough mr fruit you will
not come back
okay thank you very much okay line two
half-heartedly
okay i take the crap out of your mouth
before you call next time
okay uh gi jg chaplin you know i know
who that is
we've got a phone call ah we got a phone
call from gretchen
gretchen line one you're on the air talk
to us [ __ ] you george
was that gretchen or was that uh some
homosexual calling up here
uh thank you very much slime
one but we have no no that worries me
okay you're on the air talk to us
great crazy pig what's up
okay daddy thank you very much uh that
color was blocked so
brandon you're on the other side okay uh
you need to go down with that because
you're not you're never coming back one
buddy
talk to us
there why don't you on the air talk to
us that guy
okay lying to you on the air talk his
comments are questions for our show
tonight
okay uh uh i'm not a homophobic
but i will say that um you know the guy
sounded gay to me
i'm sorry are you making gay jokes mr
biden huh
this is what happens with all these
people it's like they all make the gay
jokes which we all make gay jokes and
i'm little i
everyone does i still do but but now
it's not woke to do it
and it's like so now it's like oh yeah
i'm all i made gay jokes in the past and
i said suck a [ __ ]
before but obviously that i mean i'm a
different person now and all these
cueing on people are the [ __ ] problem
and if you take offense to that then i'm
sorry uh well
you look bad okay 29 years old
diane talk to us hello
hi this is dianne i wanted to make a
comment to you about enrico doctor's
office go right ahead
yeah this girlfriend call in so he could
prank him
okay what's your commenter question
cause my hands right on the presser here
well i'm not gonna say anything rude
uh well i'm just really happy that
you're back and then you're back on the
air
and i think it's a great benefit to
richmond and television in general that
you return and i think the media one
should let you on all the time
he has his own wiki gorgeous show
gorgeous george show.net and he has his
own wiki
about george george yarid
george alexander yard aka gorgeous
george
g-a-y uh gay oh i get it
born uh 1968 his 52
lives in a minivan owned by a finance
company george used to live in a
tri-level house
you surf from his mother gay is a failed
public access tv host from richmond
virginia
best known for his body weight skunk
care and lack of talent and endless
years of getting trolled by the internet
internet by the goons the other years
over the years he has revealed more and
more about his pathetic life through
hours of youtube tirades and endless
phone calls recorded
uh his friends and people just call him
the [ __ ]
huh
he's also writing a book about his life
george's fat ugly ill dressed piece of
[ __ ] who thinks he is attractive to
women
uh
lack of talent so this someone made this
to make fun of him
huh george claims to be christian but to
hear him talk you think he never look in
a bible in his life not even a
children's bible
george is a man of many secrets he tries
to play off the facade of his famous
affluent even though he doesn't have a
public access show anymore he'd be
homeless
wow so i guess people have actually
been on this guy for a while huh
compared to a thin cake
do you have a fat fetish obviously you
like your women fat don't you
you like your women very thick and juicy
don't you in fact
yeah how's it going all right how much
do you pay in your bottle to be there
okay richard on line one or one two
one talk to us richard you're back
thank you
apparently this guy's been around for a
while i this is this one's new to me
but i mean good luck to him i guess